foreign
hey what's going on everybody happy
Sunday yeah going on a little bit later
than usual but yeah that's because we
were kind of running a little bit late
and also we watched a haunting earlier
today yeah so we don't have to watch it
after the show so yeah you know what I
mean and Pokey was up here a minute ago
yeah you missed it you got y'all Miss
poop she was [__] tearing up paper
and throwing a fit and trying to climb
up on people's laps and
according to Jenny she was [__]
tightrope walking across all this stuff
trying to like [__] around she's acting
a fool she is in it she heard something
and she thought Beijing was upstairs so
she had to go invest she's like yeah I
can't let her up here it's my territory
okay so um
the other day I think we mentioned it on
the main show
we were talking about we had never seen
I had never seen Wonder Woman she'd
never seen it either yeah so we went
back and watched it they they got all
the DC stuff for free or what was it HBO
HBO Max yeah HBO Max they pretty much
got all the old stuff and most of that
[__] I haven't seen
um some of it I have some of it I saw in
the theater but a lot of it haven't seen
so we're gonna I didn't see either one
of the Wonder Woman movies so we saw the
first one one woman yeah it was pretty
good
um the only thing always the thing that
always amazed me about Wonder Woman is
that it's a lesbian bondage boy fantasy
out of the damn 1950s well that's what
the comics sure started out as though
yeah sure yeah about this lesbian chick
from the aisle of Lesbos wearing next to
nothing and she had ropes and she would
tie you up she'd tie up other girls she
did it was a it was a bondage Queen so
dirty yeah it was a bondage Queen in in
the form of a comic book
and the guys who drew it made up said
that yeah that's what it was they were
looking at Benny page uh [__] photo
shoots he's in the 50s you know porn was
kind of in the United States you know it
was wasn't legal to produce they had
clubs guys that were like secretly
hiring models and they would trade
photographs and [__] but if you were a
comic book person you could just draw it
as long as it was not totally
obvious what you were doing you could
get away with it yeah she's like what
it's the lasso of Truth okay it's not
bondage yeah
and the guys that made it said it was so
it's just kind of funny you know I've
seen some of the old drawings and it's
definitely bondage definitely oh yeah
big time and Wonder Woman tying up other
girls and stuff villains villains and
[__] they were female
and by looking at and it was kind of you
know it was 50s when they're drawing it
but a lot of stuff kind of looked uh
real Varga girl type
artwork and pinup positions well Wonder
Woman started in the 40s oh did it yeah
that was 50s no I feel 40s all right
just came out the uh but evidently man
looking at this [__] and I'm saying yeah
those boys back then were probably
jerking it to that oh I imagine yeah
and Mom good didn't didn't even get it
like I said it wasn't even like they
could take porn magazines away it's like
well man it's just a comic book yeah
it's about superhero yeah so that's
that's kind of the cool backstory woman
one woman's kinky
yeah a lot of the [__] superhero [__]
was kinky well yeah well it's all like
you know fantasies it's yeah you know
for generally aimed toward like younger
audiences or at least they were back in
the old days yeah that's who they
thought was reading them something that
[__] was kind of taken the wrong way
though you have like adult superheroes
and they always have a little kid with
them yeah I always thought that was a
little weird yeah they made him stop
that
because you know it's creepy yeah I mean
even back then it was probably yeah
although maybe maybe people didn't know
what was going on back then so it's like
it didn't seem as creepy but it's
totally well the guys the um they didn't
start off that way they didn't start off
with little with little boy sidekicks
what happened was is that the uh the old
fans kind of drifted away and they had
to attract new fans who were younger and
then the marketing departments realized
well if you put a little kid in the
story they'll yeah they'll buy the comic
book which makes sense there's nothing
nefarious about that they're just like
oh well we want a character of the same
age as the target audience that they can
relate to yeah and they would go like uh
yeah you know this these little kids are
reading the comic books and their
fantasies to be like [__] Batman's
friend
you know that they're hanging out with
bad right Batman needs them right and
[__] you know and so that's where Robin
came from and they had every one of
those for a while pretty much all the
superheroes had some little little kid
little kid's sidekick even Godzilla got
one or Gojira you know [__] he had a
kitty well they all had Kenny's didn't
they go jira had a kitty camera had a
candy candy is a little
six or seven-year-old Japanese boy with
shorts short shorts on his gun ghetto
gabbara you know that's all and and he
tells the adults what to do right
without him the monster never never
would have been defeated that kind of
[__] it was that same mentality
but
the old school [__] though there was it
was sexual a lot of a lot of it was
definitely the Wonder Woman
yeah and well you know it I kind of feel
like when I was reading because they've
been trying to I don't know how [__]
sad this is but they've been trying to
get like a live-action Wonder Woman
movie off the ground since like 1996.
they had all these different iterations
of the script they had all these
different directors attached and they
just couldn't like and look at we've got
multiple Batman movies we've got
multiple Superman movies we got all the
stuff you can't even get one goddamn
Wonder Woman movie made which is like
stupid but yeah so it took that long
from 1996 to 2017 when this came out
but um Wonder Woman well she was in okay
so I haven't seen this one either
but prior to like her first appearance
and Gal Gadot played her in this movie
too was uh Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice which came out in 2016. so that
was where they introduced the character
but it wasn't she was just like a side
character you know what I mean like
because that was Batman versus Superman
which a lot of people didn't love that
so there was like all of this
um brouhaha like leading up to uh when
the Wonder Woman movie came out and they
weren't really sure how it was going to
come out they did actually use a lot of
the 1940s comic stories
um to kind of inform the story for this
one which I thought was a good idea
um also some of the 80s stuff and I
think they used some of the more modern
stuff where uh like the Greek mythology
like of her Heritage because I don't
know if originally she was like a
daughter of Zeus spoiler alert I don't
think she was that's what I mean but in
the more modern like reboot that's you
know Zeus is like her dad the thing that
thing that got me is that they changed
where she was from they renamed the
eyelid
if I remember in the original story
she was in Amazon and she was from the
Isle of Lesbos yeah there was nothing
but women she was a lesbian a lesbian
bondage Queen
which of course only some cakey
[__] are gonna come up with
that and the normies of the time I don't
think they got it I don't think they
understood probably not no well we were
discussing that because the in this
movie like the island because this is
like Wonder Woman's origin story
obviously the island that she comes from
is called um the mascara and it's like a
magical Island where it's like it's it's
not magical magical but it's like
shielded like you can't really see it so
it's like super secret yeah and I was
like I'm not super versed in the lore
like of Wonder Woman but I had always
thought that too that she was from
Lesbos and Tom's like oh I wonder why
they pulled back on that I said well one
Lesbos is a real place yeah so it's like
maybe they didn't really want to make it
a real place and two if you made it
lesbo so maybe like you know it would be
like this big thing and it's like they
probably didn't want to wade into that
Quagmire yeah so I kind of feel like
that was probably what and that's well
the implication was this is an island
they're all women they don't you know
they're all they don't allowed they
don't you know they don't really have
time they don't hate men they don't seem
like but they just don't have time for
it they're just like whatever we don't
need that [__] so they're just kind of
like that you know they did hit in the
movie that they had all this damn erotic
literature that she yeah she read all 18
books of them yeah all of all the ball
yeah all the volumes and that they
discussed men and in the end they
realized they were unnecessary right so
no they're lesbians man well yeah I mean
obviously
and that's that was the cool part of the
original story right so I wouldn't have
[__] with it but I understand that
they wanted kids to see this and they
didn't want I guess you know what I mean
they'd be asking Mom and Dad too much
about that they might have got you know
I mean they got a lot of [__]
blowback why'd you insert that well no
that was the original story yeah yeah I
think people would have whined and two
like I said I think they wanted to make
it more Fantastical and Lesbos is a real
place in case you didn't know it's a
real Island yeah but it wasn't the
island that they were talking about no
no no no I know they weren't but I was
like basically if I remember correctly
Lesbos was almost kind of like a limp of
Mount Olympus it was kind of like Ennis
in a little bit of another dimension
because it wasn't in the modern era yeah
the one that Wonder Woman came from
right her version was kind of like
Olympus it didn't exist in the it
existed but it's in a parallel universe
I think
yeah Oracle said Paradise Island was the
original island name that's what it was
from the comics well okay yeah and um I
was remembered as Lesbos also she said
she wasn't the daughter of Zeus
originally that's what I that's what I
thought because I think that was like
more modern like the more modern reboot
they actually added to her mythology and
made her like a daughter of Zeus okay
well they put that in this movie too
come on man [__] a lesbian island is
Paradise Island come on what are you
talking about through that
but I remembered it being Lesbos but
maybe they're only in certain stories is
it Lesbos yeah or maybe that was a lot
of times maybe that's what they were
talking about yeah or maybe that maybe
that's just what you wanted it to be no
I'm just pretty sure pretty sure I'm
just kidding that's what that's what
they were talking about she was in
Amazon too yeah yeah in in Greek
mythology I believe the Amazons were
from Lesbos or at least some of them
were no they got they got killed off in
some big battle mythological battle
where they were fighting all the
Griffins and [__]
and stuff Oracle says Linda Carter is
perfectly happy to have played a gay
Icon by the way yeah I mean and really
like I said that was like the last great
like Wonder Woman thing I think was like
the TV show right which I actually quite
liked when I was a kid yeah she was
spoken hot she was yeah I was a little
boy I was like God that woman's [__]
gorgeous
she was she was I was born heterosexual
man I was in a TNA tits and ass by the
time I was [__] five far back as I
could remember I was gonna get that oh
pretty lady yeah
uh yeah but uh Gal Gadot does a good job
in this
she's in real good shape the slow motion
[__] action shots of her [__]
spinning around kicking people and [__]
look fantastic because she can move
really fast you can catch bullets
deflective and stuff
and uh she's in great shape you know
she's not natural she's enhanced I think
she's doing a lot of natural loan
probably NPP but she worked out she's
just her legs are [__] great she did
yeah they said I on Wikipedia they said
she gained 17 pounds of muscle yeah yeah
she's on gear yep so um she wanted this
role really bad well and the thing about
it and I kind of remember the the the
fracas about all of this was that I
think it started when she got cast in
Batman vs Superman as Wonder Woman and
everybody for some reason like
everybody's like nah like we we don't
see it or they were pissing and moaning
about one thing or another about how
this she shouldn't do it now it's like
she wasn't I don't think she was super
famous at the time I think she'd been in
some of the Fast and the Furious movies
which I have not seen
um but I think that's where people knew
her from and they're like there's no way
like she can't be Wonder Woman or
anything like that and it's like they
screen tested like a bajillion different
women obviously because they were
looking for like the perfect Wonder
Woman and interestingly like she came in
and they said like the producers and
stuff like that said immediately they
just knew that that was Wonder Woman and
I have to say that as much as like
people pissed and moaned about her being
cast beforehand I think she just like
[__] smoked all the [__] haters
she really killed it in this role she
really captured like the essence of that
character I thought so I'm yeah and it's
the thing that they liked about her they
said was because she just embodied this
fierceness but also kindness and
compassion and they said that's exactly
what we wanted because that's what
Wonder Woman's character is like and the
director Patty Jenkins she has gone on
record as saying that her biggest
inspiration for making this movie was
Richard Donner Superman yeah because
she's like here's the thing like all of
the and I've seen like a lot of other
critics like talk about this because I
feel like like a lot of the Marvel
movies and even like the DC movies that
you know predated this one they're like
you know everybody was going for like
you know gritty reboots and like
everybody was all tortured and tormented
and dark and all this other kind of [__]
including man right and so there I think
the reason that people responded so well
to this movie was because it was really
refreshing to see a character that was
just pure-hearted and good like Superman
was in the original in the Richard
Donner movies yeah you know what I mean
and I'm not saying this isn't a dark
movie it's set during World War One for
Christ's sake but just like the way it
surprised me it was good it's good yeah
I actually really like that they did
that so this is like a period piece I
mean the first third of it is you know
her growing up on the island and then
you know then she gets like kind of
catapulted into World War One era London
because she goes there with Chris Pine's
character because she's gonna stop World
War one because she thinks Aries the God
of War has started it and then you know
toward the end like in the third act it
goes more like a traditional like
superhero kind of movie with like a lot
of CGI and stuff but I don't know I just
think I'm not a big huge fan of
superhero movies like I said oh thank
you very much Aaron E on a 10 mile bike
ride need you to keep me going all right
go ahead we got you how long is that
gonna take no I'm just kidding
um but yeah so so it kind of has
something for everybody it's kind of
like I was watching this other review
and they said uh it almost kind of goes
like from a sword and sandal kind of
Epic like at the beginning because
you're you know seeing her grow up and
like seeing all the other warriors on
the island and everything and then it
becomes kind of like a war movie with
sort of like a romance kind of angle and
then it becomes kind of like more a
traditional superhero movie at the end
but it all kind of like goes together
really well he's got the guy that played
uh Captain Kirk yeah Chris Pine yeah
he's in it he does a good job he plays a
an American spy who is like a he had
infiltrated the Germans and he shows up
in the beginning of the movie he escapes
in one of their little [__] model
planes
and get shot down
hits the Drake and
um the young one young one woman sees
him go into the water she goes up there
and saves him and she's like you a man
she didn't know what a man was
and it's just funny there's a lot of
good [__] like romance kind of like
sexual I don't know it kind of romantic
situations where she sees him nude for
the first time she says what's that you
know
but then it turned out she was talking
about his watch yeah yeah yeah yeah and
he's like and then he's like
um just all kinds of funny [__] happens
you know what I mean like uh they're on
a little boat going somewhere getting
the hell off the island
and uh
she's tried to come sleep next to him
and he's getting uncomfortable about it
she's like what are you gonna cover
before he goes come sleep over here you
know like it's just funny you know
because he's yeah because she's a man of
the early 1900s he's kind of uptight and
[__] you know and she's she's not having
it well and she doesn't really know any
she doesn't know what the big deal is
because she's grown up on an island with
all women and she doesn't really get
like intellectually she knows because
she's read about stuff but it's like
she's never been out in the world she's
never met an actual man or anything like
that so it's like she doesn't really
understand what he's so uncomfortable
about which is like really funny so
there's like up I I wouldn't call this
like there's a lot of humor in this
movie but it's not
um like over the top with it I think the
humor is like actually really good and a
lot of the humor comes from her being a
little bit of like a fish out of water
and you know just kind of like the the
misunderstandings and ensue like when
she gets brought into like The Wider
World which she's never seen before and
I have to say too that like the
chemistry between uh Gal Gadot and Chris
Pine is great like you totally buy it I
totally bought it that like the two of
them were like just the way they kind of
played off each other it's like was
really really good and I I really liked
too like the way they're different
characters but in a lot of ways they're
kind of the same too you know what I
mean because he's like obviously yeah
he's obviously a lot more worldly and
stuff and she's kind of because of her
upbringing is maybe I just you know I
don't want to say naive I mean shelter
yeah she's just very sheltered yeah um
but they both have like this inner core
of like honor and you know they always
want to do the right thing and stuff
like that so you can see like how they
connect with one she's a warrior woman
so you know she's stuff they did they
did capture the character pretty well um
it's not the same one from the 70s TV
show
uh that that version of the character is
a little bit softer she was kind of
reminding me more of the animated Wonder
Woman that you might see out of like red
Sun yeah you know yeah no it's called
called Red Sun one woman's kind of tough
you know what I mean yeah
she's not a softy uh
but you know
she's a warrior you know so it's good I
love Amazon I like to because I think
there's a tendency for movies that have
quote unquote strong female leads
um especially if they're superheroes or
spies or some [__] like that there's
always a tendency to make them
like super super tough but also like
emotionless yeah
um almost like well we can't make her
like too womany or people won't buy it
and I like that they didn't do that with
Wonder Woman and the one I'm thinking of
right off the top of the Hat was that
Cat Marvel remember Captain Marvel was
that her name yeah yeah yeah
man that character was totally Bland of
just boring through the whole [__]
knowing no emotion just yeah which like
I said I think that they lean too hard
into making her like a tough No Nonsense
which like I said but you can do that
but I think like the strength of the
Wonder Woman character is that yeah
she's tough yes she can kick your ass
yes she has magical powers but she's
she's a well-rounded person she's a
well-rounded person she has emotions she
loves people she cares about she
believes in love and all that kind of
stuff and I thought it was cool that
they did that Ellen Ripley yeah you know
what I mean [__] she actually worked
to get to become a crewman and you know
I mean he could fight an alien but she
was scared through the whole thing but
she still made it right still challenged
her you know and uh still you know
[__] it was a challenge for her you
know it wasn't just a cakewalk you know
but and other people were getting killed
and she survived right Ripley was and
Ripley was normal person she had a cat
yeah you know what I mean and she went
back to save the cat which like you said
I think people bitched about that at the
time the movie came out I was like no
absolutely not because I also would have
gone back to save the guy so alien be
damned I always thought Ripley was a
good
um heroin heroin yeah um
I also liked furiosa I thought she was
good too yeah that's another great
example where they didn't make her just
so I mean yeah Furioso was like a tough
badass but she had emotions she had
vulnerabilities yeah it's almost woman
right she was you know she's attractive
right and it just seemed like sometimes
they they kind of lean too hard in the
other direction where it's like we're
just gonna make this like this
cold-blooded kit like you know almost
more like they would do with the man and
I was like I don't really think that
that's really the way to go no I think
it's better to like about to make them
like you said a more well-rounded person
yeah don't just make them like this
emotionless killing machine right they
can be a woman and still be yeah tough
you know what I mean that's those two
things are not mutually exclusive I came
up around killing machines that was our
job in the army man making another first
and those dudes got all kinds of
emotions yeah same dude that just
[__] you don't want to [__] go up
against on a [__] Battlefield is
funny as [__] could tell jokes you know
that kind of [__] ever they're well
well-rounded is more realistic yeah and
it's I mean it's harder to do I guess
especially like in movie characters and
especially with bigger than life movie
characters like superheroes and [__]
like that you know it's kind of a
struggle to make them human but still
and I and like I said I feel like lately
like a lot of the superhero movies have
leaned too hard into and they do this
for the Men characters too like leaning
too hard into
them being
I don't know I guess like traumatized or
troubled or whatever especially they've
done that like with the Batman movies
and stuff like that where every he's
just like just this this towering thing
of angst and so I like it was really
refreshing and I think this was another
thing that was kind of just in a in a
different way was refreshing about
Shazam which was just kind of like a fun
goofy yeah movie instead of like this
dark grim and I like dark and Grim I'm
not saying that but I really like that
they made the Wonder Woman character
just like hopeful yeah she I mean she
goes out into the world and she's
horrified by World War one obviously and
she's like oh man this is like so much
worse than she and match because she
didn't know like all of that was going
on because she grew up on the sheltered
Island but even though she sees all of
this Devastation
um she still sees enough good in
humanity and still loves Humanity enough
to like want to save them like that one
[__] scene that everybody talked
talks about that's iconic of her just
like running across the No Man's Land
like across to the other trench you know
what I mean and like taking all the
bullets like so everybody else can go
over there and like [__] all the and
[__] them up in the other trench it's
like that was just such a great she
didn't even hesitate she was just kind
of like you know everybody's like we
can't do that and she's like I gotta and
she just did it yeah she brings some
stuff with her from the island she's got
a sword
and a shield totally bulletproof that
sword I guess is uh what was this deal
behind the sword I mean the sword was
supposed to be well I kind of feel like
do I have to do spoiler alert yeah this
movie came out like what like six years
ago yeah and I feel like probably most
people would say but it sure was the god
killer yeah yeah was what it was
supposed to be now did she lose that at
the end yeah Aries broke it yeah that's
right I thought so because as it turns
out spoiler alert the sword was not the
god killer
and then she's got the she's got the
lasso she's got the bondage rope yeah
that makes everybody tell the truth
she's got the bracelets that she can
stop bullets with that she didn't no she
didn't know that they did that because
remember like at the beginning
you know in the first third when they
had the big uh fight like when the when
the Germans came like after Chris Pine
and they started attacking the island
and
um you know a bunch of the Amazons got
shot because all they had was you know
bow and arrows which they were kick ass
at yeah but they still got killed a lot
of people they still got shot but they
killed a lot of the Germans too like it
was pretty a lot of people got killed
the Germans had bolt to action rifles
right Mauser 98s but um I mean had had
Wonder Woman her name's Diana for
Christ's sake yeah had Diana known that
you know her uh her arm things could
deflect bullets she probably would have
saved her aunt yeah she had a tiara what
did The Tiara do did that um I don't
think the Tiara does anything I think
it's just there all right because it
doesn't do anything does it I don't
remember it doing anything yeah because
that almost remind now that you
mentioned that that's crazy because that
always reminded me of Percy is in Clash
of the Titans where he got the three
things he got like The Sword and the
shield and the helmet like the helmet
made him invisible and the sword could
like cut through marble and then the
shield he used that for uh reflection
like to kill Medusa and all she also had
shin guards I think those stopped
bullets too didn't it didn't they
because yeah when she had the shield I
think her just her shins would stick out
to the bottom yeah I think they were all
catching machine I mean that was armor
yeah that was she was wearing the suit
was badass
I really liked the the design of it yeah
it was just kind of like a pleated War
skirt and like a like a corset and a bra
basically pretty much yeah and a tiara
that was one of the one of the funniest
[__] things is when she first comes
to London and of course she's never been
there before and it's like so she's
obviously she's what they put like a
cloak on her or whatever so she wasn't
just walking out of this like shiny
armor which everybody'd be like what the
[__] it's like 1918 or whatever it is
and um so they have to take her to like
get her some clothes so she doesn't look
all conspicuous and everything and she
is just like not having it like they're
putting into all these constrictive
clothes like what we were wearing at the
time she's like trying to kick she's
like is this the kind of armor women how
could you do anything in this position I
feel your sister she started just taking
her clothes off too yeah well she didn't
know what he did for it and like I said
I like that they they did that like kind
of funny fish out of water stuff but
it's not like they were making fun of
her it's just kind of like on her Island
why would you have to go somewhere to
dress right and and you and you as the
film and watching the film like really
do relate to that it's like you know
where she grew up it's like you wouldn't
need to wear all that [__] and if
you take well they took their clothes
off though right they're Greek yeah you
know what I mean they they didn't have
even the concept of nudism they just
didn't wear clothes sometimes right
they're just like what's everybody so
upset about yeah it's just a body
everybody's got it they were all women
anyway and it didn't matter you know
everybody looked at you know everybody
and they all another thing is is that
all those all those women on that island
look good yeah they're all hot they
didn't have any fat women there they
were all in great shape well because
their whole thing was they trained all
the time because they were sure that
Aries was gonna come back at some point
and like try to defeat them and that was
kind of their whole thing was they were
supposed to defeat Ares when he came
back so they had to be ready yeah at
Aries if you guys don't know that's the
that's the Greek version of the god Mars
the war god
you know the one that Rob Halford's
always singing about
yeah with like centered Exciter and [__]
he's talking about Mars
yeah well that was the later Roman yeah
yeah right
Oracle said uh the scene where Diana and
Steve Trevor in the boat was improvised
by the actors for the most part we'll
see now that makes it even more because
that was like a good scene I really
liked that scene a lot because it was
just you could tell that they kind of
liked each other it was like super
awkward and it's just like and she well
he was a lot more Awkward than she was
because she just didn't get what he was
like so awkward about which I thought
was really funny
um Oracle said the original comic Tiara
let her understand all languages oh it
was she's oh okay we'll see they didn't
okay so they do that in the movie like
that she understands that because she
said oh we understand like all languages
or lots of different languages but they
didn't specify that it was The Tiara
that did that she could just do that
because when she came there like she
talked to that one guy in like Italian
and Chinese and then like she talked to
that Native American guy yeah um and
they speak in ancient languages they're
dead yeah and she and then she
translated that the book that one of the
villains had that was in like Sumerian
or some [__] like that like she knew
what it said and she's just like you
idiots can't read this come on you know
what I mean which I thought was really
funny because like you know it's 1918 so
she walks into like the war room and the
big meeting and everything that's like
oh my God there's a limited here get her
out of here you know what I mean and it
was like hilarious she's like why can't
you guys read this it says this and the
other thing and it's just like okay
what's like so funny but they don't want
to listen to her you know so we gotta
see uh 1984 Wonder Woman 1984. that's
that's for free on on
um HBO also HTM Max has got all pretty
much all the DC yeah I think I was
[__] Justice League and all that I
haven't seen any of them so I'm gonna
look check them out one of them is got
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman in it
that's one that she showed up in right
yeah Batman versus Superman colon dawn
of Justice yeah which came out a year
before this that was the first
appearance of live action okay Wonder
Woman and it's escalgado yeah it's so
yeah it's still her and um yeah so that
was when she first appeared but like I
said I don't yeah I haven't seen it
either so I don't really know how big a
part she has in that but I'm actually
kind of happy because what I was she has
a little part of Shazam she does yeah
and she shows up in the second Shazam
yeah yeah like Fury the gods or whatever
it's called because Shazam has like a
like a fan like a dream about her or
something I recommend both Shazam movies
even though the second one flocked I
thought it was good I liked it too I
liked the first one more but the second
one was actually really good too there's
nothing wrong with the movies it's just
Studio system and the rock kind of help
[__] it up and [__] but because with
Black Adam that wasn't the original the
way it was going to go
and um I think all that infighting there
caused people not to want to see the
movies it's just a shame because uh yeah
I'd see a third shazam movie I probably
would too I actually really like that
character yeah and well here's the sad
thing about Wonder Woman though is this
movie came out it was a massive success
not only critically but it made like a
[__] ton of money and actually for a
long time it was the highest um grossing
movie by a female director until I think
like last year like in or 2021 like
another movie came out that was that
beat it but for a long time this was you
know the one it made like almost it made
almost a billion dollars I think like
900 million or something like that and
massive success all the critics loved it
everybody loved all the all the you know
Fanboys loved it which is crazy because
normally you wouldn't get that and then
Wonder Woman 84 came out which we
haven't seen yet even though that's but
that might be the next thing we watch
we'll see we might watch it tonight baby
yeah I mean I wouldn't mind almost see
it yeah I mean like I said it's as long
as it's not like [__] four hours long
because I don't think yeah but yeah I
mean I don't I wouldn't mind seeing that
actually but I heard that wasn't like I
heard mixed reviews of that but like I
said that doesn't really mean anything
to me it's like because none of those
people are me so it's like I don't know
yeah I don't think it did that well at
the Box well and that's the thing they
were actually supposed to make a third
Wonder Woman movie but now they're not
gonna do it I guess because Wonder Woman
84 didn't do as well even though which
is stupid because it seemed like when
this came out like I said everyone was
just like in [__] raptures about it
and like how awesome it was and it made
so much money and then for some for
whatever reason like 84 came out and
people just didn't like it I was like I
can't imagine yeah that it could be that
much I don't know it's just I I one
thing I like that this was set during
World War one I like that they went
period piece with it which is a risky
move but I think it paid off I mean I
think it really because it kind of
hearkened back it almost kind of
reminded me of like the older like the
Captain America movies that were like
set back in World War II yeah like it
was kind of like that so it was like
that kind of vibe and like I said it
gave me that kind of Superman that
wholesome you know old school like
Superman kind A vibe too and which is
cool because that was kind of no one was
really doing that like in superhero
movies so like I said it was risky move
but they pulled it off they did a lot of
kind of homages with it that some of it
kind of reminded me of like remember uh
uh Land That Time Forgot the German
submarine show yeah yeah like that you
know what I mean and the people that
time forgot some of that
was in there you know almost kind of
like uh
for a seventh Voyage of Sinbad some
Sinbad type stuff was in there you know
they're on an island
you know with Greek stuff yeah and then
Modern Man shows up that's like that was
like some of those old
land of time for God isn't that what I
think so yeah German submarine so it is
old like Edgar race Burroughs yeah yeah
you know a little bit of that kind of in
there it was kind of homage in that a
little bit
um I thought it was a good movie
was it a great movie I'd have to see it
again yeah it takes me a couple times
seeing it before I ever really though I
watched like a and read like a wide
variety of different critical like after
I watched it I don't usually like listen
to critic [__] before I see something
but after I see it I'm kind of
interested in other people's
perspectives to see if people see it saw
it the same as me or you know if I was
wildly Off the Mark or they were or
whatever so I watched Lynn read like a
bunch of different reviews of it and
pretty much to a man like everybody
loved this [__] usually the only
criticism I saw and I saw this more than
once was a lot of people didn't like
they didn't love the villain
um especially there's kind of two
villains or actually kind of three
villains but there's two villains who
you think are like the villains like the
whole way and they're switching there's
another one like towards the end but
people thought the villains were a
little bit over the top or a little bit
cartoonish which I don't know if that's
the case they were slightly over the top
like especially what was that dude's
name duceled no it wasn't Dusseldorf
would it was something like it was
something German it was the German
general guy and then the poisoner
yeah I like the poisoner lady too like
with the ceramic face that was like
pretty cool
I liked that she was but one I don't
think they were in it enough to but I
think that was kind of some of the
things that were like well the villains
were kind of like underdeveloped and
then there was like this third act
Switcheroo where it's like oh well those
guys they were villains I'm not saying
that but they weren't like the big bad
you know what I mean and I think some
people thought was like oh we would have
preferred there just to be like one
clear villain and like you know that she
was fighting against and [__] like that
but I kind of liked and the well and the
thing about it was that and like I said
I'm sorry if you haven't seen this
because I'm kind of spoil it a little
bit but Patty Jenkins the director her
intention
was to make the movie that there wasn't
an Aries you know what I mean yeah um
that after she stabs that guy thinking
it's Aries and she's like what the [__]
I thought the war was going to end and
then she kind of becomes disillusioned
and she's like oh [__] like it's he
wasn't a real guy it's just this is what
humans are like which is there is like a
whole conversation like that that she
has with um with Steve you know what I
mean but then she's like so she's like
so I'm making the movie I'm making the
movie it's like going along and
everything's fine and then the producers
were like no there has to be Aries like
what and she's like we don't have time
to do that now and they're like no you
have to do it so she basically had to do
it like she's like okay well Aries has
to show up and there has to be like a
big boss fight at the end pretty much
but she was gonna have it that there
wasn't an Aries right that makes more
sense actually yeah that was her
intention yeah and my complaint about
the villains would be Aries
when Aries when you first see him he's
kind of in a disguise he just likes and
looks like a normal guy of the period
but then when he shows his true self
he's in this armor and everything
and he's you know doing magic basically
God stuff God stuff uh the armor that
he's in looks like something out of a
Marvel
a bit yeah it was too spiky and red and
[__]
no he should have been in Greek armor if
he's [__] Aries he should have been
in that would have been bad actually he
should have been like a Greek hoplite
with a sword with a spear and a [__]
Shield
and because that's that's what that's
how Aries was basically kind of drawn
he's kind of like a Spartan or something
and that would have that would have been
a lot better
because that would have matched he could
he should have basically looked like
Wonder Woman but just that just a male
outfit of that
yeah that's now that you mentioned it I
think they would have we'll see because
the thing about it I think DC they kind
of were like
the thing about it was they kind of were
behind Marvel right because Marvel like
got on the whole extended Universe train
like way earlier and DC was seemed like
they were kind of scrambling to catch up
so it's like some of the movies they put
out like the main complaint about them
from like DC fans and stuff like that
was that they seem to muddled or they
seemed to they were trying to cram too
much into the stories because they were
trying to catch up to the Marvel [__]
it's like no we need to get to Justice
League we need to get to the big mashups
you know because Marvel's already done
that like years ago and we're behind so
um so they were kind of doing that but I
feel like that's why everybody I think
that's another reason everybody was kind
of happy about this movie is that they
actually took the time to take one
character Wonder Woman and do a whole
two and a half hour movie just about her
and about her origin story with and they
didn't put in another thing that's cool
they didn't put in like a bunch of
Easter eggs like to the extended
Universe the only Easter eggs that are
in this I think are at the very
beginning when there's like a truck in
front of the Louvre that says Wayne
Enterprises on it and and then like at
the very very end which is like setting
the modern day like she's sending an
email to Bruce Bruce Wayne or somebody
like she said it like somebody else in
the DC I can't remember who it was now
but that was literally it they weren't
they didn't have like [__] Captain
America popping up they didn't have like
any other wolves Captain America one
pop-up but you know what I mean but they
didn't have like other characters like
popping in and they're being like hey
I'm in this universe too it's like so I
like that they didn't do that they
refrained and there's no mid credit
sequence there's no end credit sequence
we watched
um so I kind of like that like I said I
thought it was like kind of refreshing
it didn't do it does some of the stuff
that superhero movies did but it does it
didn't do like a lot of the stuff that
superhero movies do that I don't really
like yeah I think part of DC's problem
why it became why DC is kind of a kind
of a jumbled mess really and it's so hit
and miss even even though in general I
enjoy DC movies better than the I do too
slightly it depends on what it is but
what I would have done is not really
paid much attention to Marvel and just
try to cut out my own identity yeah
because well yeah ideally because DC
characters are not like Marvel
characters DC characters are older
they're a little more
um they're more mythological and yeah
they're almost like fables so really the
the storytelling should be almost kind
of semi-religious
yeah because they're like an American
mythology
you know so I wouldn't they're not
really grounded in reality like uh
Aquaman I thought was good because
Aquaman was Pure Fantasy we saw it yeah
they leaned into the fantasy element and
you're in the underground shots I'm like
this is basically Flash Gordon under
underwater yeah and that was the proper
tone for that movie I was like yeah
that's it you could each when DC was
doing its [__] back in the day they
never thought about combining all these
together in big mashups each character a
lot of times is in its own Universe well
because they all had their own team of
writers and artists and stuff like that
they weren't really talking to one
another they were just putting out books
for kids to read yeah and each one of
them had its own tone and really that's
it's good when like they did with Shazam
Shazam had its own tone it's hard to
believe that Shazam and Wonder Woman are
in the same universe even though they
are yeah but the tone of the movies were
like they were in separate universes
yeah it was totally different but that's
really the way they should have done it
um kind of keep it that way each each
character has its own tone don't worry
about Crossing them over I wouldn't
worry about it because I don't think for
the most part the comic books never did
cross over they did it would be later on
way late you know yeah I mean they did
do that in the comics but like like we
said it's when it started out in the
comic books they didn't really give a
[__] about it at any of that extended
Universe Jazz they were just kind of
like yeah this team over here works on
Wonder Woman and this team over here
works on Superman and it's like they're
just like whatever we're just doing a
story and they put out the books like
like I said for kids to buy for a nickel
and [__] like that they weren't worried
about continuity they weren't worried
about this that they just wanted a good
[__] story and I think that maybe I
guess because of what Marvel did and I'm
not saying I'm not [__] on the
Marvel movies because some of them are
really good but the fact that they did
this massive massive extended universe
and made all the money in the world now
everybody has to do that like everybody
had everything has to be extended
Universe now which like I said and I
agree like I think DC at the beginning
should have said yeah you know that's
obviously a way that we can go and
they're making billions of dollars doing
that but it's like should we because
they were so far behind you know they
probably shouldn't have even tried like
you said they should have tried to carve
out their own Niche and they could have
just put out which I guess they've kind
of done to an extent but you know more
than Marvel has I guess because Marvel
seems like they very much try to keep
everything you know tight and like
within the same parameters but whereas
DC is kind of more sloppy in a way like
they don't really think about it but in
a way that seems like they're trying to
cram everything into the same universe
but they're not really succeeding it
kind of comes out more like that so and
like you said but I did like what they
did with Shazam because that's like its
own thing even though it's the same
universe as Wonder Woman and Superman
and all that and Wonder Woman actually
does make a cameo in the second shazam
movie which we brought up but it's not
the same tone as it no because this
movie I mean it has humor in it the
Wonder Woman movie but it's still really
serious I mean it's set during World War
One like lots of people like a whole
village gets gassed and dies which is
horrible like you know what I mean so
it's so it's serious and grim and
everything like that but it has kind of
an undercurrent of hopefulness to it if
that isn't too weird to say you know
what I mean like in the same way that
Superman did like I said so you could
actually tell that the director
um you know Patty Jenkins she was like
she was super into like the Richard
donor Superman and she wanted to make
something along those lines yeah well I
would think really pretty much all of DC
stuff should have been Donner
donner-esque really I think that's what
DC's tone was yeah I think [__]
I think Donna called it that that's kind
of what DC's tone was in general there
was definitely DC stone for Superman
yeah and he knew it now like I said
before he
really
for me we're getting at a superman but
for for me [__] Chris Reeves is
Superman all right he just yeah it's
like I said it's kind of hard to top
that he was and and much like Gail Gadot
or um Gal Gadot does in this movie it's
just kind of she kind of embodies that
role in a in kind of the same way that
Chris Reeves yeah for me I would say
Chris Reeves with Superman Superman one
and two was good Superman two uh
daughter Cuts even better Superman three
very mundane poor Richard Pryor man
because he was a huge Superman fan he
loved those two movies he wanted his
movie to be really good but they just
didn't have the right people on it and
it just man I I never could get through
the damn movie Superman 4 was [__]
Canon films which is actually better
than three it's a [__] show it is a low
budget [__] show it's [__] crazy but
there's something about it that I like
it is
and Chris Reeves doesn't phone it in man
Chris Reeves does [__] Superman do
the thing
I mean I mean mad props yeah for him
yeah because well I think the nuclear
man thing might have been his idea
[__] crazy so that might be why he
was so invested yeah maybe it's like a
nuclear man I think that was his idea or
the whole anti-nuclear thing I think
yeah didn't they give him a producer
credit on it I don't know I don't know I
did I've only seen it twice and it's
just [__] it's a [__] show but it's
kind of fun it is kind of fun it's kind
of fun I mean it's bad but it's yeah and
it was a missed opportunity because you
that didn't have it looked good for a
low budget movie
the titles they should have skipped the
titles because they couldn't afford
those [__] daughter titles for the
first two uh you know the opening
sequences they could have just done a
real simple opening sequence that would
have been good enough
and they should have had a badass
writing
you know you could do a nuclear man but
it could have been done better you know
nuclear man really should have been
played by Chris Reeves it should have
been an evil twin clone
that's what I would have done
somebody got a whole you know like
what's his name Lex Luthor got a hold of
Superman's blood his DNA somehow
because then he get a hold of his hair
yeah that's right yeah yeah he had his
hair then he uses nuclear power to make
a clone
of Superman and then kind of brainwashes
it so there's two Supermans and one of
them is a mutant
that would have been a better one that
would have been a better uh story
and then like Superman tries to make
peace with him but then it doesn't work
out and [__] the nuclear man tries to
become real Superman and and tries to
take over the earth type of deal
thinking he's a better Defender than the
old Superman and you know it's a fight
to the death to have a deal brother
versus brother that's way it should have
been yeah the dude that they had with
the [__] hair and the suit and
everything it was entertaining but it
was just corny as [__] yeah it's
ridiculous but that but you know comic
books are important not intimidating at
all Superman comic books are kind of
corny I mean at least in modern
superhero movies the villains are
actually like scary most of the time
they've updated a lot right they've
updated the genre a lot uh well they
take it more seriously now than a lot of
people did they didn't back then no it
was kind of goofy and so they just kind
of leaned into the goofiness
kids liked it and adults just kind of
laughed at it yeah
but uh
although still four could have been
better yeah with the budget that they
had but I will say I think that because
you know I know I keep comparing like
this movie to like the Richard Donner
Superman but I think the reason that I
keep doing that is because Chris Reeves
and the original Superman that character
I kind of feel like under anybody else's
like in anybody else's hands that could
have gone really wrong because the
Superman character at least in his Clark
Kent iteration and even into Superman
iteration is pretty like a goody
two-shoes right and so that character if
you don't get the right character like
actor playing that that can get real
grading and real corny like real fast
but I think the best thing about Chris
Reeves and that role was that he's a
total goody two shoes and he's just like
a Boy Scout like they say in the movie
but you still love him like he's still
really endearing and I think the same
thing applies
in this in with uh Gal Gadot in Wonder
Woman is that she comes across she's not
quite as much a goody two shoes as
Superman is but she still very much has
that believes in the power of love and
peace and everything like that I mean
she's also a warrior and can kick your
ass like I said but she's very much like
like I said like a very sheltered
character and that could go drastically
wrong like it could be really corny or
annoying or something like that but to
me it's like it didn't come across as
corny at all like her character does not
come across as corny Aaron says we made
we we got her home yeah
that's good I'm glad yeah
um and Oracle said this was a while back
but Oracle said uh kudos to Robin Wright
by the way she was the one that played
um The General
the aunt uh Diana's aunt in the movie uh
yeah she was great and her role as the
general [__] man I'm just glad to see
Robin Wright man I still remember her
back from [__] The Princess Bride
back in the 80s she was [__] great in
that and she still looks [__]
fantastic that's the girl that was in
off of uh Battlestar Galactica wait or
the other one was we're talking about
the girl from bat a woman from Battle
struggle actually the one that played
was on the Mandalorian she's the female
Mandalorian remember she was in there
yeah that's right no I'm not sure please
Starbucks I'm talking about somebody
different okay I'm talking about the the
woman that played um the ant the one the
one that trained oh Diana yeah okay yeah
that's Robin Wright all right
um but and Oracle said I liked how in
the movie that Tiara is in honor of her
aunt who'd mentored her in the Art of
War yeah that's right that's right she
got the Tiara from the like her aunt had
it all right uh Oracle says seriously
you all need to watch the series Julia
too the cooking stuff will appeal to Tom
is that the one that's about Julia Child
because yeah I've been wanting to see
that I haven't wanted to see that uh
Oscar says hey Oscar what's going on it
says uh Gal Gadot is gorgeous yes she is
I agree and um yeah she really she
[__] killed it in this role and
honestly we haven't watched 84 yet we
might watch it like after this live
stream is over because I kind of want to
see it I'm curious but um especially
after seeing this one and I really like
this one a lot and like I said I'm not a
big huge fan of superhero movies but
this was actually like a really good one
yeah I thought Gal Gadot [__] nailed
it just the acting her physique
how she looked that that's the character
and like I said that's and that's a lot
like the animated versions uh you know
of the character just she spot on she's
got a fantastic body
fantastic body how old is she I don't
know I don't know actually okay I mean
she doesn't yeah she looks like it she's
in her 30s yeah I would imagine but yeah
like I said she's she trained hard for
this role because she really wanted it
well everybody everybody wanted this
[__] rule 17 pounds a month 17 pounds
and how much time I don't know okay I
don't know so if a woman putting on 17
pounds of muscle
that's gear man yeah probably an NPP or
naturalum
with [__] it's not like you just take
that and that happens to you you gotta
trade
to get that transformation
but uh no I respect she she looks great
yeah and she might have done that before
the Batman versus Superman because yeah
she was in yeah I'll eventually get
around to watching that one too like
it's I'm kind of like I said I'm kind of
over Batman movies at this point I've
seen a lot of good Batman movies but I
just feel like we don't really need any
more Batman movies because it has a lot
of them how many [__] Batman movies
does one Universe need seriously there's
like so many but um you know and I
haven't heard a lot of good stuff about
Batman vs Superman like a lot some
people liked it but they thought that it
was just too overstuffed like I said
that they was just trying to do yeah
like they were just trying to cram too
many stories in at once we'll watch it I
heard there's different edits of it some
edits are better than the others aren't
there like there's supposed to be a like
a longer edit that makes more that makes
more sense but like I said it's like two
movies right you know
okay well we'll get around to that one
but I kind of I want to see Wonder Woman
84 first because I actually really do
like uh Gal Gadot in this role and I
like this character and the her
character is more interesting to me I
guess than Batman because like I said
actually not as much I've seen all the
Batman movies and I've seen a lot of
Superman movies too and you know I'm
kind of like meh but you don't really
see Wonder Woman [__] all that much so
it's kind of nice to like see something
that's just all about her and I think
that's like pretty cool so uh so yeah
all right so tomorrow is Monday of
course and that means it's time for
haunting Mondays we're gonna be talking
about some more ghost story [__] yeah uh
so the one that we're gonna be talking
about tomorrow we've already watched and
I've already taken notes on
and it's called what the [__] is called
Black Magic Black Magic uh so season six
episode three yeah
um season six was only four episodes I
didn't realize that until I was like
looking at the disc so I don't I guess
it got canceled and then it got yeah
moved like later picked up later but
yeah so that's the one we're gonna be
doing black magic we watched that
earlier today so hopefully you can join
us for that tomorrow evening at 7 30
Eastern Standard Time so until then have
a good rest of your weekend you guys and
we will see you again tomorrow evening
good night